florido
siamo fatti sono stati oggi continua la
nostra simulazione di ben 100 anni
andiamo auto bild che ho detto che se
avete raggiunto il ceco via vi piace
avremmo continuato a una simulazione di
vita li ha raggiunti che invece questo
video 17.000 vi piace continueremo
trovata senza vita all'universo un bel
mi piace su note mettetevi comode
incredible tornerò voglio dirvi dai parà
ferito abbiamo andato al temine inizia
subito vediamo cosa ci aspetta allora
ecco la nostra scelta dobbiamo scegliere
se andare a sinistra o destra viviamo
chiesto decidete voi se andiamo sito
intranet tra i tantissimi se avete detto
destra in tanti si dice tanto a sinistra
però ora maggior parte erano verso
destra vediamo se avevate ragione
vediamo ok
stiamo correndo verso il corridoio forse
siamo riusciti a scappare le di natale
ora le buone con le sorelle zoe
poverino no devo rifare e devono
sbloccare il piccolo guarda guarda lo
sta facendo
massimo le aree insomma perché ci avete
detto destra ce l'avete detto a forza
oppure non lo sapevate un quinta teach
avete anche detto sinistra quindi alcuni
di voi avevano ragione ora andiamo
andiamo essere speriamo che toglie la
strada per scappare considero altre
guardie che siamo usciti corridori dai
dai dimmi che la via della libertà nasce
niente
c'è un buco qui dobbiamo scendere giù
nelle fognature nelle fognature
eh sì forse questa sarà la volta tutta
la barca va fatto foglio trattata siamo
sempre a 39 anni vediamo se siamo
riusciti a scappare
sono le condutture persona o che
speriamo di non incontrarlo ingresso un
pagliaccio ecco delle scale quasi fuori
dalla prigione allora anche se abbiamo
ancora questa tutina possiamo certo
scappare ma non sopravviveremo mai
campioni nel deserto ci sono per tempo
forse non possono salvarci aiutatevi
salvatemi vi prego non ci fanno delle
domande che noi siamo vestiti così come
i rimpatri dei prigionieri e cerchiamo
evasi dalla prigione e magari sono evase
anche loro siamo ancora vivi non è
possibile ma siete sopravvissuti accanto
certo ancora sopravviviamo ecco ci
stiamo solo nella nostra tenda sono
finiti i nostri amici iniziando
abbandonato qua esploriamo torniamo a
casa e diventi tornare a casa perché
secondo me succede quando esploriamo
quindi torniamo a casa madre ma ieri ci
siamo dice già innamorati di qualcuno
che non è olga questa volta per la
ragazza qui abbia un bambino a fianco
che succede
cambia il posto con la mamma oppure
rimani lì perché il bambino elias
piangono quindi però c'è la ragazza che
mi piace
ecco quindi non so se scegliere di
rimanere lì per la ragazza oppure
cambiare il posto con la madre secondo
te secondo me cambiare posto secondo voi
che dovrebbe farsi così la madre sta
vicino al bambino ok vediamo riuscirò
comunque parlare con quella ragazza
vediamo o no bisogna sbagliarlo bianco
sono fatto un upgrade al posto migliore
l'ha messo prima tratte in realtà la
scelta era giusta perché ci hanno messo
in prima classe però non abbiamo poi
conosciuto quella ragazza che avrebbe
cambiato il nostro destino
stiamo certo ma tornato ma c'è qualcuno
che sia adeguato alla casa mentre era un
membro in zone dove sta andando
vediamo cosa succede oppure la carta di
olga no questa sarà casa nostra
fiori dopo i cori i genitori ma scusa
quello erano seppelliti nel giardino di
casa ma senza genitori
no va bene sta diventando tristissimo la
vita di questo ragazzo offrire piangendo
spero che non sia per colpa nostra che
sono morti per qualche nostra scelta
dice il primo aiutato scappi mentre
dentro caso sì perché magari è successo
qualcosa e poi scoprire che cosa è
successo
vediamo scopriremo qualcosa aiuto
secondo persone essere poi ci guardiamo
se qualche indizio e state attenti anche
voi sembra tutto che poverino
e sconvolto la polizia ma no non vi
diremo noi oppure ci hanno ritrovato
perché perché stiamo ai fatti già ne
stanno scappando da fare qualcosa non ci
posso credere molto alla polizia
ok ora devo scappare l ortigia scappa
scappa scappa va evolutissimo ok siamo
entrati nota sicuramente la polizia
continuerà a cercarci perché siamo aveva
dobbiamo stare supera attenti con le
scelte adesso perché è sempre più
difficile di fax ci ha portato in un
hotel succederà adesso
una stanza dobbiamo stare rinchiusi qua
senza farsi trovare dalla polizia
e come faremo a pagare la stanza di
ferrara dai 43 o forse ce la faccia
avuta in un pub a un bar
abbiamo bisogno di foto cmc diventerà un
pericolo capello ex il cuore bar e non
sta vivendo le nostre battute sera di
natale bordi che riproviamo forse siamo
noi viene da comico
qual è l'animale più stupido della
giungla la scimmia o l'orso polare
due su tutte la scimmia perché posso
parlare come nella giungla perché fa
molto ridere diamo come reagiscono
quindi dovevo scegliere l'orso polare
non vi ammazzo perché faccia ridere
questa è come lo sono con te ti sto
vedendo come matti abbiamo una carriera
come comici crediamo che sono arrivate
altre persone magari diventeremo
favorirne mentre mali ma se diventiamo
famosi quella polizia si riceverà le
celle che in galera dice l'hotel ha
trovato ad abitarvi 10 dollari in più
per l'aria condizionata
me ne sono andato senza pagare o beh
quasi un gioco di parole in inglese e
che vuol dire non è molto bello non è
molto figura in inglese si dice che il
pregio di re trasacco quindi un gioco di
parole con l'aria condizionata ha sei
anni siamo ancora vivi vediamo cosa ci
aspetta che stiamo continuando
continuiamo a fare i nostri sono quindi
stiamo diventare un modo che periodo che
stiamo vivendo
c'è un sacco di gente che voleva vederci
la polizia perché i cimiteri anno il
recinto le mura ben effetti morti non
possono scappare perché giuliano perché
le persone muoiono dalla voglia di
entrarci nel cimitero o per proteggerli
dai ladri dito dei cimiteri
beh fa più ridere la prima si è blu e un
pesante light blue o acqua l'aiuto
sarebbe un gioco di parole perchè la
juve sarebbe il celeste chiaro indy
lights per l'inglese può dire sia
leggero che è chiaro quindi light blues
on call per la cassiera costino 47 anni
stiamo andando in aereo e dice dammi
quella bottiglia posso avere un
bicchiere meglio bayern vediamo come
mistero questo siamo diventati ricchi
con le tue mani d'oro
e poi diventati famosissimi wow su per
te altro tutto per noi
taranto 8 ho come l'impressione che
andrà a finire molto confronto cosa
porti all allora come chiami una radura
strette altro picco di mirtillo anche
fare il gioco di parole in inglese
perché blu in inglese vuol dire sia il
colore blu
mi sa che sei un po triste menti è
blueberry è stata voluta perché un naso
non può essere lungo 12 e non so quanto
sono incentivi verdi cm per prima perché
sennò sarebbe un piede oppure perché
pinocchio non è reale come fiori che
secondo me va bene uno dei due lo voglio
niente finocchio vediamo
speriamo speriamo che ridà allo stremo
che ridono le banane
ok la battuta era il piede perché ma
questo è un piede si chiede come unità
di misura
io non avevo capito che voleva dire
quello il piede l'unità di misura
comunque 49 stiamo babudri che succede è
arrivata una fan e dice abbraccia la o
chiedile di andarsene poverina
abbracciamo la sono entrati altre fa
allora la maggiore circondando no non
era quella forse era quella del
l'appuntamento sull'altro sarebbe
successo se avessi detto alla fan di
andarsene sono curiosa dove siamo in
aeroporto si fino a che punto sei anita
dai di marco al basket battuta diverte
come chiave una calcolatrice che
funziona subito che ho una call call
calcolo adesso proviamo incollate come
che hai fatto da brutta vediamo se
quella giusta calcola adesso
ma il matrimonio a tre anelli l'anello
di fidanzamento l'anello di matrimonio e
quale altro anello e il signore degli
anelli o software che facevamo gioco di
parole inglese perché sofferenza e
l'influenza discesa quindi la fine della
parola e cioè l'anello quindi penso che
sia quella vediamo
mi raccomando studiate le toghe come
capirete tutti i videogiochi tutte le
app qualsiasi cosa non solo perché
importantissimo da studiare ma anche
perché capirete tutto 51 anni vi abbiamo
cosa ci aspetta siamo in verità è che
abbiamo viaggiando sempre amore non
sapere di gluck che capiamo dall'aereo
siamo tutti è il mio incubo presidente
erio allora età o seduto o salto seduto
un paracadute no no non ce l'hai occhi
di malisse venuto vediamo cosa succede
ma come fa continuare a volare l'aereo è
rotto e non è mai verificata morti prodi
allora bisogna ci avviamo sapevo di
avere il partito secondo me sei plessi
accettiamo veniamo cadendo in un isola
si facciamo per fare non è un arma era
eviterà la nostra nuova vita in quest
isola deserta siamo siamo atterrati
tranquillamente sull'isola no non mi
dire che stiamo pensando il giocatore di
tori poverino cosa succederà adesso
chiamo dolci da soli in un'isola deserta
non riusciremo a sopravvivere da soli
vediamo che cosa c'è esploriamo concerto
intitolato guarda ci si può un totem
stiamo salendo sull'auto roland roma per
i pezzi
ecco le immagini più difficile aiuto o
se in silenzio secondo me è meglio stare
insieme senza sbarre invitiamo non mi
dire che sto morendo di fame
forse ci trovavamo chiedere aiuto che
questa volta chiediamo aiuto però
pensavo mi volete dire una freccia
l'opzione sì ma ancora nell'isola quindi
vediamo come continua la nostra vita
nell'isola
andiamo a combattere così
unisciti all'allenamento oppure dopo
meglio che visto perché meglio che
impara difendermi a mietere duca che
bello sono io che sto facendo anni for
radicando dopo 1 anno a dopo un amico se
c'è un gruppo no ma che i capelli mi
sono cresciuti tra procedevo normale da
53 56 abbiamo saltato tre anni che
strano che potrebbe di un inizio la
sicuramente proverà costruire una
zattera infatti lei mi manca pensando
lascia base ma lottando
sì ma come tanto ama nuotare vuoi
rimanere il panel isolo vuoi andartene
dopo come faremo ad andarsene dice forse
prova in valutare impossibile morirei
subito oppure costruisce una barca
ricostruiamo una barca abbiamo in legno
l'albero di amos provando a costruirla
mago ho l'impressione che
che cosa trasporta però che non rubare
devo provare nuotare ma è impossibile
nas colmi mangerebbe lo stesso vediamo
mi sembra strano che riesco ok vediamo
che succede con la zattera con la scuola
aiuto possono squadra che ci aiuta
se facciamo la birra dello squalo ma che
di noi siamo ricascati una nave e ora ci
giochiamo la banda con chi stiamo
crescendo ora invitiamo forse vediamo a
quasi all'improvviso mi sono caduti
descrizione e la barba bianca e semo in
montagna dobbiamo scegliere fra due
strade lascerà un teschio e lascerà un
animaletto 15 ieri dove andava
l'animalier solo sinistra quindi stiamo
facendo un'escursione per 6 1 6 1 motta
[Applauso]
bene allora scappi corri oppure fai
finta di essere morto preferito di
essere morto bene qual era la soluzione
con gli orsi montorio e mai di essere
morto vediamo se funziona aiuto bisogna
certa mangiando no si sta odorando di
devo correre anche se mi sembra strano
ho paura che hanno inviato sa bene come
che succede da adesso siamo bloccati in
via d'uscita dovevamo scegliere un'altra
strada
lo prevedesse possiamo farli scegliere
tutti dovevamo scegliere quindi la
strada a destra e mai seguire i cuccioli
di orso bruno la mamma maggiore dove
siamo finiti
sono cose a dare una favolosa cimitero
con dei fantasmi fra l'altro fantastico
di colore che cosa un mezzo per terra un
tramezzino il suo mezzino di barents è
grave perché io sto scappando quindi ho
lasciato qualcosa di sto scappando
non so cosa piace mangiare le fantasmi
non mangiano che ne sai non ho capito ma
e rocchi stiamo abbastanza 66 73 come
l'impressione che tornando indietro
siamo al casinò succede qua e dove può
giocare abbiamo in realtà
godendo delle carte cosa succederà
ho due assi quindi bene sono in
vantaggio allora che cosa faccio metto
tutti migliori oppure passo ben noti
come o due us ti metto tutto dice che
cosa il vecchio come vecchio perché non
passi invece io ho messo tutti i nemici
anche lei ha messo dei soldi vediamo di
vincere cosa succederà vediamo un po
ecco un asso napoli non ha dato quindi
tris di affi viola finora lo partito
allora un 27 quindi non è granché re lì
ha un senso che dobbiamo farlo chi
società devo spiegare guarda a un segno
in due
cosa si può ancora se ne sarà accorto
spero di no perché adesso più capelli di
s salta due ruote non so quello che ho
fatto
come stai forse siamo dal merito ho
fatto uno scan e sembra che è il cancro
al colon o no un cancro quanto mi
lasciano vivere ai due minuti 8 minuti e
basta o due minuti
com'è possibile no non ci credo più può
solo due minuti per me siamo riuscite
stiamo sognando forse stiamo ritornando
giovani ma che sta succedendo siamo
tornati bambini forse stiamo sognando
stiamo sognando o forse stiamo morendo e
quindi siamo tornati bambini e succede
stranissimo sedia 22 salice scusati
spaventato non andare in questo buco qua
ok per che cosa succede se vado qua
andiamoci forse s'è fatto pamojo ci ha
spinto a somma che succederà ha detto
ancora rotolando no sarà morto allora
sono sopravvissuto fino a stesso sono
due anni ho guadagnato 53 mila dollari
la mia carriera era di un com loro la
mia forza era 65 per cento
non mi apposita 30 per cento e ho fatto
sei anni in prigione cosa sembra
infinito gioco e credo proprio di sì no
abbiamo finito fuoco guardia 73 moro
senso mi piace se volete che continuiamo
magari riprendiamo da quelle scelte ma
cercando di cambiare strategia ridotto
pro vivere 32 anni lasciato un buon
ingaggio barbotto e al rischio ma poi
deve deve applicare per vedere i nostri
altri video linkato su quella che
preferite